il part à cannes et c'est pas que pour
le festival
ya passe à manger la ja passe à manger
la
ville a déjà fait ses deux matches comme
ça riaj pourquoi je peux lui casser la
gueule non mais il a
parlé we do pilar ouais ouais j'arrête à
l'autre ainsi reste peu papa regarde il
est brisé désormais regarder le regarder
ils suent à grosses gouttes et open où
il a rendez vous à cannes il a un rendez
vous à cannes et c'est pas que
professionnel à revoir après si j tu
continues nima sur les soirées
libertines atteignant
j'ai rien dit c'est
pas la fin de jal mais moi j'y vais pas
et donc voilà enfin réunies pertes n 2
je ne fais jamais toujours une libertine
alors j'ai bien vendu comme esclave a
créé chuchotements que coûte une boîte
à nier non plus
je peux pas nier non plus la réponse
sexuelle pardon et des perceptions et
sept principes sava transmédia longtemps
mais là non mais j'ai pas de problème
avec ça ce n'est pas un reportage sur
les soirées un salon sont ils faits
n'étaient pas il n'y était pas mais
c'est vrai que gill était un adepte des
soirées une austin comme vous dites
on est au moment où on m'a attaché en
laisse et où il fallait que jose
[Rires]
avec un choix derrière moi j'ai arrêté
tout il rédige stop franchement j'ai dit
wow quelle excuse moi mais pour quelques
années encore le journal sur les traces
de dsk parce que moi à l'époque ce
reportage chez denise tu vois des
missions denise c'était une boîte de
nuit rue quincampoix venise qui était
une boîte c'est ça et moi j'ai tourné a
tellement vrai à l'époque et je rentre
dedans il y avait un type qui était
enfin qui se faisait claquer les faits
sa cave et une boule dans la bouche et
jeudi c'est qu' à l'époque on se
connaissait pas et on dit c'est le
patron du parisien je te jure c'est vrai
c'est hyper choquer tout ça et c'était
il ya des années et cette egypte
c'est la
boule la boule dans la bouche ce n'est
pas pour connaissance je sais pas mais
moi j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie ne
serait comme ça jamais vraiment de la
boîte
j'étais à d'autres mais pas là bas était
au 10 bis nom et où quelques bouche à
oreille le plus d'eau plus de faire
depuis deux t2 quoi
vous plaît s'il vous plaît on redonne un
petit peu sérieux